[Musique]
vivre en france est un privilège quand
on est sans papiers on ne vit pas sur le
territoire national dans la plupart des
pays du monde quand on est sans papiers
on est expulsé
on ne rentre pas comme ça au panthéon de
manière bruyante pour offenser un haut
lieu de la république peut pas continuer
dans ce laxisme c'est bien du laxisme
les personnes qui ne respectent pas nos
lois qui sont en situation irrégulière
etc
je ne vois pas ce qu'elles font en
france le 14 juillet c'était la grande
fête de l'unité nationale c'est la fête
de la fédération
qu'est ce qu'on a vécu dimanche c'est la
fête de la fracturation nationale des
fractures nationale où ces jours
derniers des additions de minorités se
permette de salir la république le
gouvernement ne cesse de répéter nos
élus nous sommes dans un état de droit
nous sommes dans un état de droit mais
appliquer la loi fait en sorte que les
personnes qui qui ne la respectent pas
soient sanctionnés le c'est un tel qu'il
est et tel qu'il est appliqué
aujourd'hui met à mal la filière bovine
française
d'abord parce qu'il déstabilise cette
filière sur la partie haute gamme de la
viande maple aloyau en tant que tel et
surtout par ce qui fait qu'on plie
comporte un risque sanitaire sont donc
il y à un sujet qui motive de notre part
non pas une hostilité de principe parce
que les accords commerciaux ne sont pas
par nature pas par essence mauvais la
devenu protectionnisme avait rappelé
qu'ils peuvent être bénéfiques pour
telle ou telle filière mais nous
demandons nous allons déposer une motion
d'ajournement il faut le dire aux gens
qui nous regardent
cet accord autorise l'importation en
france dans des proportions très
importantes et des taxes et de boeuf qui
seront nourries avec des farines
animales qui elles sont interdites en
france depuis la crise de la vache folle
et il ya sur ce secteur la viande bovine
un risque très important
il ya d'abord un risque de
déstabilisation de la fille d'une
filière entière qui déjà fragile tu es
toujours l'agriculture que la variable
d'ajustement des accords commerciaux
ça ça n'est plus possible c'est un
double mauvais coups d'abord sur le plan
symbolique puisqu'elle n'est plus
ministre d'état s'affaiblit deux
ministères en tout cas symboliquement ça
affaiblit
la réforme de la transition écologique
comme si c'était plus important avant
les élections européennes qu'après les
élections européennes
et puis c'est aussi un coup d'arrêt
parce qu'un dame bornes c'est quand même
celle qui a réduit le fret ferroviaire
en france et celle qui a fermé beaucoup
de petites unités d'air en france et ses
excès qui considère que les quatre caps
ne pollue pas forcément donc je suis les
signaux qui sont envoyés aujourd'hui ne
sont pas forcément des signaux positifs
en matière d'environnement de transition
écologique
c'est un ministère comme beaucoup avec
ce gouvernement dans lequel les actes et
on le voit bien avec ce remaniement ne
sont jamais à la hauteur des mots
[Musique]